this is a crazy story Ben Dixon who
guest hosted for me yesterday talked a
little bit about the for Green Berets
who died in Nazaire and we've since
learned a lot more about the aftermath
of those four deaths and how President
Donald Trump reacted to it and we
learned about a phone call that Donald
Trump made in fact to one of the widows
of one of the fallen soldiers her name
is Maya Johnson she's the widow of Army
sergeant Lee David Johnson who died and
and she received a phone call not long
before her husband's body arrived at
Miami Airport and there was a huge
dust-up that started when Democratic
congresswoman Frederica Wilson said she
spoke to the widow
Myesha Johnson and that the widow said
to her Trump told me my husband knew
what he signed up for talk about lack of
empathy talk about total lack of
connection as a human being with someone
who has suffered unimaginable loss as an
experiencing grief now of course that
doesn't make Trump look good the fact
that my Isha Johnson said Trump called
me and he said plaintively your husband
knew what he signed up for Donald Trump
took to Twitter and on Twitter Donald
Trump called Fredrika the congresswoman
Frederica Wilson a liar saying a
Democrat congresswoman totally
fabricated what I said to the wife of a
soldier who died in action and I have
proof
sad published the proof Donny boy if you
have it but here is the congresswoman on
CNN saying no no no Donald Trump is the
person who we believe him to be Donald
Trump said what I said he said and she
says she has proof here's a clip from
CNN as president Trump is now responding
to the controversy involving his call to
the widow of one of the fallen US
soldiers killed in Nazaire his tweet
reads Democratic congresswoman totally
fabricated what I said to the wife of a
soldier who died in action and I have
proof
sad that congresswoman Frederica Wilson
joins us now good moring congresswoman I
know this is the first time that you're
hearing the president's tweet read to
you so when he says that you've totally
fabricated what he said to the wife of
the soldier and he has proof
what's your response well I don't know
what kind of proof he could be talking
about I'm not the only person that was
in the car and I have proof too this man
is a sick man
he's cold-hearted and he feels no pity
or sympathy for anyone this is a
grieving widow a grieving widow who is
six months pregnant this is a young
woman she's only 24 years old she weighs
maybe a hundred and ten pounds and she
has two other kids two years old and six
years old and when she actually hung up
the phone she looked at me and said he
didn't even know his name
so now that's the worst part he didn't
even know his name now what's likely
here let's apply a sort of general
version of Occam's razor what is more
likely Trump is the hugely uncaring
disgusting unyk
that we've seen him be in every aspect
of his public life but he was really
nice - this one grieving widow or
Frederica Wilson is simply correct here
and particularly when the families of
other fallen soldiers have said yeah we
haven't heard from Trump either
political reports about Sheila Murphy
just as one example whose son died in
Syria in May in May of 2017 she has yet
to hear from President Trump despite
writing to him that some days she
doesn't want to live if Trump has proof
provide the proof but there's a growing
list of these incidents where Donald
Trump claims to have proof and he
somehow never provides it remember when
it news leaked or surfaced or was
published that Trump's wife Melania
Trump was in the country working
illegally and Donald Trump promised
during the campaign we're going to have
a press conference and we're going to
you're all this up with some proof that
never happened remember Obama wiretapped
me at Trump Tower soon I'm going to give
you information and proof about that
that never happened
the congresswoman says she has proof
which I'd also be interested to read
more about but these are battles you
can't win once again Trump is picking a
fight with a gold star family before it
was the parents of a deceased army
captain you remember that one from the
campaign this time it involves the widow
of a deceased soldier I could not agree
more with the idea that if if there are
more and more military spouses
significant others who are saying half
jokingly but also it's a serious thing
to their spouses if you die I don't want
to hear from Trump and I could not
empathize with that feeling more how
would a narcissistic sociopath calling
you in a moment of such extreme grief do
anything for you and I can't believe I'm
saying this because this is the type of
thing the right likes to say and it's so
cliche I'm sick of Trump disrespecting
the military constantly he dodged the
draft multiple times for his bone spurs
that he couldn't even remember the
details of years later and he cannot
stop disrespecting the military
absolutely disgusting and I can't
believe we've come to a point where I'm
talking on my program about how I'm
furious that the president is
disrespecting the military today's
program is made possible in part by Blue
Sky binary have you heard of blockchain
blockchains the new trend in technology
and on the Internet and too many people
are not aware of both the power and the
risks of blockchain technology some
people think it's too complicated it's
too difficult to get into so people stay
away and they miss out on the
opportunity to really know about the
opportunities that blockchain presents
but it doesn't have to be this way and
the solution is the blue sky binary
blockchain academy blue sky binary is a
leading financial education and
technology company and they're turning
their attention to blockchain they've
launched their blockchain academy to
complement their other successful
training programs and they've created a
blockchain edge
Haitian course for beginners and active
crypto users alike and in this score
course students will be taken through a
series of topics which ultimately will
deliver a solid understanding of how
blockchain works and help the student
realize the current and potential future
uses of block tank blockchain technology
we've talked about some of these on the
bonus show and on the program and the
course includes video on-demand online
tests access to a community of traders
and blockchain enthusiasts who exchange
knowledge and experiences and you can
register now to get a 3 day free trial
that includes access to the first module
of the course for you to evaluate the
overall quality of the program and
afterwards it's 49 and 99 a month you
can stop and resume at any point
checkout blueSky binary.com slash david
to sign up today